foreign
[Music]
I get it I know it's hard but like this
is the time
like Magnus he stepped down and I I
obviously it's different but like um
what's going on hang on hey I just think
this is my time to be because my shot
like I want to be a master I've done
everything I can here and um
yeah I appreciate you listening and
let's talk more
I just want you to know that I'm
stepping down as CEO I'm going to become
a chess master
and I was wondering if you watch no no
okay nope
lovey thanks so much for taking some
time with me I just wanted to share the
news with you that I'm stepping down as
CEO of chess.com and I'm going to
potentially pursue uh trying to become a
master and I was wondering are you
interested in being CEO chess.com
I'm just extremely dumbled by that you
even thinking agree if I'm completely
honest
um and I mean it's a no-brainer for me
guy I've just got to say no
oh I'm uh I'm surprised to hear that how
come
just think I'm bigger than chess.com at
this point
Yep this is Eric yep yes CEO of Chess
Eric
now he said like John Wick 5 is in the
way
no no Arnold Schwarzenegger was a total
zero chance Prince Harry is he into he
into chess on and I wanted to ask you
Alex are you maybe potentially
interested in being CEO
I don't think I could be part of a risky
startup again so soon but we're not a
startup uh okay Andrea what about you
yeah and I have to focus on my boxing
career right now it's a lot of hours I'm
sorry
hey xqc
hey uh yeah really quick any chance you
are in no I'm not in the bathroom no no
I'm not in the bathroom I'm not in the
bathroom
um so I'm stepping down as CEO and I was
kind of wondering like is there any
chance you want to be CEO
well first of all a dude you can't
afford me and second I literally don't
care
got it is there any chance you maybe
want to be my personal coach as I'm
trying to be a master
uh no absolutely not
got it okay well thanks for listening
whatever dude yeah thanks for getting
back to me yeah I understand I know Mrs
Daddario is like an actress and
everything but she also like tweeted
about Chess
wait she set up the boardroom
oh dude you're totally right okay never
mind all right thanks
[Music]
oh that's cat
after 15 years as a sea of the chest
when I come I am stopping here to focus
on being an actual chess master
[Music]
no no
I'll know
I'm looking for a new CEO
apply share
tweet
[Music]
foreign